I've been thinking a lot about risk
recently partly because the new scar on
the face and partly because I'm sitting
on pulpit rock in the South of Norway
with nothing between me and a 600 meter
drop it is a very very long way down and
it is very windy but how risky is this
really I mean millions of people have
visited pulpit rock it's not a difficult
hike families with kids come up here all
the time and yet in living memory only
one person has ever fallen off it
walking up here it's probably more
dangerous driving to the base certainly
is and yet this has been called one of
the world's scariest tourist attractions
as it is humans have battled assessing
risks that's not news you know that but
would I still be here would he still be
sitting on the edge if the consequences
were different let's say theoretically
that at some future point Humanity has
cured all disease including
aging no one gets old no one gets ill
technically you are immortal but you can
still get hit by a car or fall off a
very high rock a decent maths
an average modern healthy Western person
has about a 1 in 2,500 chance of dying
from an accident every year it's a rough
estimate but those odds mean that one in
five of those mortals won't live to see
500 years one in three don't see a
thousand sure that's a long life but
it's not immortality you still die trans
humerus would say they're well they're
able to back up their minds all they
need to do is live long enough to live
forever that's right as well but if that
turns out not to be an option then the
on way to survive would be to avoid all
risks now in English we use the word
live not just to mean our bodies working
but to represent experiences like this
it implies that hiding away in a bunker
avoiding risk is somehow being less
alive but if you really have literal
immortality if you thought you'd survive
into eternity would you live like this
take those actually be quite scary one
in 2500 odds over the year knowing that
at some point your number will come up
or do you hide yourself away never leave
a a safe bunker knowing you won't
interact with the world but knowing
you'll grow old with it you will find
out what the future holds ultimately
which is more human the desire to
experience all the desire to survive I
don't know the answer and I suspect it's
somewhere in the middle because some old
part of my brain with millions of years
of evolution guiding it has already made
the decision for me because I am sitting
on this bit of the rock